we're plowing through the summer unless
it's a uh
that's of course it's a rebroadcast
maybe you're listening to this years
from now and it's and maybe you're in a
part of the world where it's not only
winter but it's freezing out so me
talking about the summer is just stupid
now and through the summer we're plowing
through the summer I I'm gonna tell you
of course
no you know what I have a um I got a
cold last week and uh my throat's a
little iffy and so just my throat wasn't
working correctly for a second and it
was a crucial second because I'm
podcasting to billions of people around
the world right now dude with a sore
throat how do you plow through the
summer yeah well I'm going to and you
had a cold last week we saw you last
week and you breathed overall it does
this to us all the time yeah I just
think it's a celebrity cold welcome to
have it you can sell it on eBay oh Jesus
anyway my point is joined by Sonam
Obsession Matt Gourley and the point I'm
making is that I used to have a lot of
anxiety I was very happy about the
summer obviously because I didn't like
going to school and when the summer
would come the minute July 4th was over
I started getting anxious about oh no no
the summer it's going too quickly you
know how do I slow it down and then
suddenly it's July 15th and you think no
oh this is awful it's almost August and
it was just this terrible and then I
would ruin the summer because you were
worried because I was worried about the
summer and I know and I had that problem
too did you have it seriously yeah I
loved staying home from school so much
that I almost couldn't enjoy it I always
enjoy the day before a day off more than
the day off yes isn't that horrible I
understand that yeah I always liked sort
of late Friday afternoon was my favorite
part of the weekend because technically
the weekend hadn't started yet yeah and
then once the weekend started there was
all this anxiety about it's going too
quickly no yes that is not me at all I
enjoyed it up until Sunday Monday
morning you don't get Sunday Blues no oh
I would get terrible Sunday better I
didn't even know that was something
people have oh I used to bust out my
harmonica oh my God and I made and I
used to sit on my front porch in
Brookline Massachusetts
you guys just didn't enjoy yourselves oh
I made my room into a prison cell and I
just rub a cup against the bars you
don't rub it you wrap it you rub it rub
it rub it in your room purely sexual
thing you guys did never do rub a cup
come on I can't wait you're good
everyone's gone I can rub this cup
against These Bars takes away the Sunday
Blues let me tell you that much anyway
uh yeah and so now I don't have it as
much as an adult because uh I don't have
to go to school again in the fall yeah
but I had it a bad case of it so I'm
just thinking about this because I
remembered feeling the countdown
happening after July 4th and having some
anxiety about it but that only gives you
like a few weeks where you actually
enjoyed your summer it's a curse it's
not a good thing I'm surprised both of
you were like this we're similar in a
lot of ways admit it yeah no we are we
have similarities you know we're taking
a break for this show the the listeners
won't know it'll continue to come out
steadily but we're taking a month off
we're not going to see each other do you
think like three weeks or two even one
weekend you're gonna start to go oh no I
have to go back no because you enjoy it
because you love us I do enjoy doing
this I'm not gonna make a joke I do
enjoy hanging with you guys but uh this
will give me a chance to really get in
shape
sorry this show is sponsored by better
help so I know you're uh very busy yeah
you've got twins yes twins who are over
two now they're gonna be two in July
it's very easy to find yourself uh doing
things for other people or trying to be
really productive and get a lot done and
take care of everybody I know you're a
caretaking personality yeah I am so are
you and and what happens sometimes is
you'd realize I haven't checked in on
myself I have no clue how I'm doing yeah
I bring this up because I'm a big
believer in talk therapy if you if you
can find the right fit right person and
getting help it's made a huge difference
in my life yeah in some ways I've been
your therapist over the years you have
been you've been and I and I think that
you're if you didn't want to prayer I
don't want to pay someone so I figured
if I could just talk to you I'll just do
it for free but it is so it is important
to talk to someone if you're thinking of
starting therapy maybe give better help
a try here's what I like about
betterhelp it's entirely online this
didn't exist back in the day when I was
maybe looking for someone to talk to and
it's such a smart way to get involved in
this process better help is designed to
be convenient flexible and suited to
your schedule find more balance with
better help I really think this is a
terrific idea visit betterhelp.com Conan
today to get 10 off your first month
that's better help
h-e-l-p.com slash Conan I'm surprised
because I thought you liked school and
you're like Yay I got to learn again in
a few weeks no I was very anxious about
school oh okay yeah a lot of anxiety
about school especially Elementary
School fourth grade fifth grade sixth
grade seventh grade all three I mean it
was anxiety provoking for me I was a
crier you cried yeah they dropped me off
is that true yeah I would cry I would
scream and cry yeah sometimes I see you
outside the podcast Studio crying and
you've just been dropped off by your
mother yes and you have a note on your
shirt that says hi
my name is Matt I'm allergic to nuts I
would still like to be viewed as a tough
person but I was a Christian
I don't want this to hurt my perception
that people have of me yeah as a you're
a tough guy who cries and when put in
prison the first thing you'll do is take
your cup and rub it against the bars
in an erotic ecstasy
hey can I tell you something this is
completely taking us in a different
direction here boss but
um it's something that popped into my
head recently and now it's taking me out
of every TV show or movie I watch which
is when you're watching a TV show and I
may have mentioned this before but
sometimes my family and I now that we're
all together again my daughter was off
in college but we're all back sometimes
if we want to all do something together
we watch say like an old a vintage
Gossip Girl you know and one of the
things that I can't get out of my head
is they'll show a scene will start with
the elevator opening and a guy coming
out like Chuck Bass or one of these
serious characters coming out and giving
some grave news fast and um or like this
old guy who's supposed to be a senator
or a captain of industry who's the
father of one of these young people the
elevator door opens up and he comes out
and all I can think about is how it's
not a real elevator that the actor oh
yeah has to sit in there and tell people
on either side pull the doors open and
he comes out and so it's kind of in my
head now and I'm noticing it in all TV
shows and movies now if you're watching
a high class movie yeah sure it's a real
elevator and the door shuts but in a lot
of cheesy TV shows especially from the
90s 2000s
a character will say something like you
haven't heard the last from me
I'll be back and when I am back you'll
all wish you were dead and he'll step
onto an elevator and there'll be
dramatic music and the doors shut and I
know that the actor is now just standing
in a box
oh it just shut the door
yeah does anyone else think about
this
let's just get ruined Star Trek for me
all those 60 Star Treks where I just
know that Kirk is like we've got to get
to the transporter room immediately
let's go and he and Spock Rush In And
the door is shut and I know that there's
two guys getting union pay to move the
doors shut why do you have to think this
and now
they're standing in there until someone
else cut just don't don't see it it's
too late stop thinking I have the
potential if I spread this idea that
whenever you're watching a TV show and
someone gets on an elevator and says a
dramatic line and the door's closed or
it gets off an elevator
I'm sorry it's going to take you out of
the TV show it's going to ruin it for
you it's an elevator
and there's two guys on either side that
are closing a door and then they're
eating a sandwich afterwards and saying
hey did you hear the Japanese bomb Pearl
Harbor well how do you feel about that
it's like scenes that are shot in
airplanes and submarines and stuff that
aren't cars or cars yeah oh first of all
it's just the idea that they get in a
it's so yeah embarrassing that they have
to get in a box and say something like
I'm going now up to the top floor the
very top and when I get there all your
careers will be ruined door slide shut
actor stays in trapped box until two
Union guys stage hands opened the box an
actor has to come back out and see all
the people he just told off you guys
both suck no you suck you no you suck
come back Hey listen to this you suck oh
good one I won yeah well I'd like to try
one yeah you try you suck yeah hey wait
a minute you're pretty good you both are
ruining summer and you're ruining
elevators what are you happy about what
do you guys like what do you like
Santa why did you say it like that Santa
Claus what are you Hans Gruber and like
Santa Claus Santa Claus I don't like
this okay okay you've made your point
yeah but I think the bigger point is
when an actor gets in an elevator okay
now it gets out of an elevator you
ruined something I'm not gonna ruin
that there'd be a screener and all those
years before we knew you Matt and I was
doing the late night shows all those
years it sort of worked for me they
would set up a screening for a movie
every time we'd go and see a movie when
it was over someone would say I loved it
and I would say you know because we saw
everything you'd see everything and we
saw some really great movies and we saw
some movies that uh even the actor and
who's the star of it would come on the
show and the commercial break it going
yeah I know not so good but what are you
gonna do and I go I thought it was
pretty good no come on let's face it
every time someone would go
someone directed it hundreds of people
like swept up the set and built it
that's exciting and that's good for them
sometimes we would watch a terrible
movie and you would get mad at me I'd go
like I don't know that movie doesn't
make any sense I mean they introduced
the character of the brother in the
second act and then he completely
disappears and then he's a walrus in the
end and they never explain you'd go they
made it
[Music]
can we just all agree and I think we can
all agree that summer goes by too
quickly yeah okay yes no it doesn't and
but the main point that I think we all
agree on nope is that nope when an actor
gets on an elevator
or it gets off an elevator they're
getting into a box that's going nowhere
and to me that is a metaphor for the
political state of America today oh my
God we're a box going nowhere no let's
just enjoy things just enjoy something
yeah Santa Claus Here Comes Santa Claus
I think everything I enjoy
able
people make things and we that's good
for them yep good for them good for them
all right let's get this show on the
road shall we yeah hated a lot of good
stuff too settle down yeah and you're
like like the third act hmm you're the
worst they're the worst to watch movies
with all right I didn't mean that you're
actually really fun to watch movies with
you were really cool about it anytime an
actor gets on an elevator they're
getting in a box here we go